even though it doesn't really look particularly
appetizing it does manage to cook him breakfast
as messily as possible the symbiote is kind of
like a goat it could digest anything in organic
matter he could eat a tin can like a goat and it
would still be able to digest it that's why they
have all the jokes about not eating people like
literally they open on that joke in his apartment
while it's cooking breakfast no eating people
the song is playing is that louis armstrong ella
fitzgerald song let's call the whole thing off and
that's just a metaphor about their relationship
before they start with a different song one is the
loneliest number about a couple of the different
relationships during the trailer like there's
the idea of the implied relationship between
the carnage symbiote and the venom symbiote they
also used that loneliest number song to play on
his relationship with anne wang and play on cletus
cassidy's relationship with shriek his girlfriend
from the comics in the maximum carnage storyline
which they're actually basing most of the movie on
they're mixing a couple different carnage and
venom stories from the spider-man comics so
they're mixing the maximum carnage storyline with
his origin story which are completely separate in
the comics i don't know how i feel about the venom
symbiote singing that song but it does a good
job of showing you how they've changed the way
they've tuned the venom voice so the venom voice
is actually just tom hardy's voice processed in a
very different way it's the exact same way they're
going to be doing the carnage voice as well but
you don't hear the carnage voice you only see
carnage and then you hear cletus cassidy speaking
when he's not carnage but throughout the trailer
you see him reading the daily bugles website
which is our first big spider-man easter egg
and it probably has something to do with the
article that the detective is reading in the
separate scene in the print version of the daily
bugle now the other really important easter egg
here for the spider-man movies isn't just for
the tom hall and spider-man it's actually for
toby maguire spider-man because the daily bugle
logo on this here is the same logo from the toby
maguire spider-man movies i'll explain what kevin
feige said about crossing those characters over
in a second he talked about tom holland jumping
cinematic universes like he jumps the multiverse
we also have the idea that spider-man 3 no
way home is incorporating some spider-verse
multiverse elements in the film so that
could be one of the ways they explain
all these inconsistencies because it seems like
venom 2 wants to make a lot of references to the
sony spider-man movies including the andrew
garfield amazing spider-man films because we
have the ravencroft institute which was featured
heavily during the amazing spider-man 2 when they
were setting up the sinister six they brought back
mrs chen and they've explained that she knows all
about what's going on with the venom symbiote they
have the twist on the joke from the first venom
movie trailer where they had him eating that guy
who was actually trying to hold the convenience
store up only this time apparently the whole idea
is that in the couple years since the events of
the first film he's been protecting her and she's
been paying him back quote unquote paying the
symbiote back for protecting her in exchange for
some special chocolate which apparently is late
in the venom symbiote is furious about and wants
to eat her no no we can't eat mrs chen wait what
what are you talking about they jump back and
forth between a couple prisons in the film yet
the state penitentiary the cletus cassidy was
being held in during the first film he's still
there he's on death row but then they also flash
with shriek his girlfriend who's in new york city
inside the ravencroft institute on the other side
of the country also new york city kind of in the
area where spider-man is so you can see they're
slowly moving the plot of venom two to the new
york city area to put him in proximity with the
spider-man character and even though you don't see
it during the events of the trailer they kind of
imply that the carnage symbiote makes its way to
new york city to try and free her after it escapes
from prison the director of this movie is andy
circus he actually did some commentary clarifying
that during the events of this film the characters
are unaware that spider-man himself exists this is
the clip of him talking about that obviously there
are links between venom and spider spider-man in
the marvel universe and the spider-man story but
in this you know we're treating this very much
as it hits his own world the venom story is his
own world there are nods and and little moments
that that you just like this newspaper the daily
bugle of course but on on the whole he's unaware
they are unaware at this point of other characters
like spider-man that's that's that's the way we've
chosen to play this particular episode of the of
the movie but well we'll wait and see we'll see
what what little uh things you can pick out of
it you see that eddie is still going to see cletus
cassidy the way they explain it during the trailer
is that article about the hidden victims of cletus
cassidy apparently trying to find all these hidden
bodies that the authorities never found when
they initially captured him but they never fully
explained how the carnage symbiote is created
where it comes from during the film i'm assuming
for now without more footage that it's just based
on the comic book explainer that it spawns from
the venom symbiote and at some point during some
of their meetings when he's in the prison it
spawns eddie doesn't realize what's going on then
the carnage symbiote just bonds to the first thing
that it finds which happens to be cletus cassidy
that's basically what happened in the comic book
version only in the comic book version eddie brock
was inside the prison cell with cletus they were
cellmates and when the venom symbiote came to
break eddie out of prison the offspring bonded
with cletus cassidy and you have the carnage
symbiote then cletus cassidy narrates the rest of
the trailer talking about their relationship while
they sort of intercut with the other relationships
during the film like anne weighing in the shriek
character but we have to say how they mercifully
cut his hair i am so happy that they got rid of
that weird wig from the first venom movie they
intercut with venom taking out more criminals on
the streets remember the bargain that he made with
it during the events of the first film he said
we're only going to hurt bad people cletus talks
about them leaving people behind as they intercut
with the anne weighing footage obviously she's
a big part of this film she made some comments
about doing more lady venom scenes during this
film so she might also get the symbiote again
briefly during the events of the film they don't
explain too much of what's going on with shriek
but the whole idea is that ravencroft is a place
where they put the criminally insane and some
supervillains with special powers which it seems
like shriek does have her special powers from
the comics it's basically like a banshee sonic
scream if you haven't read the maximum carnage
storyline shriek just teams up with the carnage
symbiote during that now these scenes are from
new york city so he climbs up on that building
next to the gargoyle looks out over it they do
this big white city shot they move the plot to
new york city by this point in the film very overt
twist on a spider-man reference here so you have
cletus cassidy who seems like he's writing a note
to send to eddie brock the note that he's actually
reading when the symbiote is cooking him breakfast
earlier in the trailer it's got the same red ink
on it so it just seems like he's sending eddie
mail but you also see the red spider climb up and
he smashes it just meant to be a clever reference
to spider-man's classic spider bite origin story
but unless they get really twisty though i don't
think his origin story has anything to do with any
kind of spider bite i still think it's going to
be a twist on the classic carnage storyline from
the comics you could also look at him smashing the
spider as a reference to him fighting spider-man
eventually too i think the whole idea is they
would love for venom and spider-man tom hall
and spider-man to team up and fight carnage in
a future film because that is basically what the
maximum carnage storyline is and probably one of
the reasons why they save that title for one of
the movies like why they call this movie let there
be carnage instead of just calling it maximum
carnage we see him on death row they're getting
ready to execute him and as they start to pump him
full of the drugs that are basically going to kill
him the carnage symbiote just explodes out of his
body so at this point in the film he's already
gotten the symbiote we just don't see that happen
and he talks about becoming chaos which also you
could think of as a reference for that classic
carnage storyline with cathone the god of chaos
although i don't think they're even getting close
to cosmic during this film and that's a very
cosmic carnage story there's this whole idea
that there's a prophecy about carnage inside
the dark hole they just featured the dark hold
inside the wand division series because there's a
prophecy about scarlet witch in it scarlet witch
is crossing over into doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness in doctor strange 2 the movie is coming
out right after spider-man 3 no way home there's
also supposed to be some crossover elements with
spider-man inside the morbius movie and now the
morbius movie has been rescheduled and it's coming
out just a couple weeks after spider-man 3 no way
home comes out in theaters so towards the end of
the year there's going to be a lot of spider-man
related stuff happening now this scene of the
building burning down seems like a completely
different place than we've seen before so this
might be the orphanage where carnage grew up as a
child or where cletus cassidy grew up as a child
because a little while later in the trailer
there's a scene of it not burned down like
completely whole and you see the carnage
symbiote all over it attacking these cards
i believe this scene is also supposed to be in
the new york city area so it's happening later
in the film obviously after carnage travels to
new york city this is venom inside new york city
swinging around the buildings using the symbiote
very much like spider-man would do they show you
eddie going to meet with this detective character
who seems like he's a pretty big person during the
film probably just another person who's trying to
pursue cletus cassidy seems like he's really upset
about the idea that he did not discover a bunch of
bodies that cletus apparently buried somewhere and
it seems like the venom symbiote doesn't like him
either like it's trying to eat him and he has to
stop it this footage of the cell block just seems
like it's the cell block where cletus was being
held and it's in the middle of his big prison
break you guys can let me know what you think
about the look of the carnage symbiote during
the film it looks like they're trying to base
it on some of the more recent comic book designs
but they're trying to make it as red as possible
without actually making it deep saturated red like
they want it to look as different from the venom
symbiote as possible while still making it look
kind of like the venom symbiote it looks like
this is happening in some sort of industrial park
probably before a big fight scene with the venom
symbiote then they end the trailer with a sort
of post-credit scene like the trailer has its own
post credit scene with carnage inside the church
in front of that stained glass window so obviously
there's a big church fight scene which is a cool
reference to the comic book origin of venom which
they obviously changed during the events of the
first film because of all these toby easter eggs
during the film with the daily bugle kind of
makes you think of the tobey maguire spider-man
3 movie where they did try to do a comic book
accurate version of venom's origin story with
the church bells very biblical putting him in
front of this church in the stained glass window
that also kind of gets into the prophecy and the
dark hold about carnage being the end of the world
this big prophecy about how he's going to bring
about this great destruction i know a lot of
people are wondering if they're ever going to get
to knowl the god of the symbiotes in any of these
venom movies that would be like their version of
avengers infinity war in avengers end game i think
sony would love to build up to a cosmic story that
big but i have no idea if they're going to get
there and i think right now they're mostly just
focused on crossing over tom hall and spider-man
with the venom franchise then if the rumors are
to be believed more live-action spider-verse
action because you have all the rumors about tobey
maguire and andrew garfield coming back as their
versions of spider-man but just a big reminder
the movie is coming out september 23rd couple
months before spider-man 3 no way home so we'll
see what other easter eggs they have in trailers
later this summer there'll be more trailers in
the next couple of months but everybody just
let me know if you spotted any easter eggs in the
trailer that i didn't talk about during the video
obviously because of all the implied spider-man
easter eggs during the morbius trailer and morbius
was originally supposed to come before venom
2 i think we're all expecting some sort of
legit tom holland cameo scene like a post-credit
scene explaining how he eventually crosses over
there was also the easter egg from the morbius
movie with the daily bugle article same version
of the daily bugle because it's the same logo
which says where is spider-man but this is
supposed to happen during the morbius movie not
venom 2. hopefully in the next morbius trailer
they'll have more overt spider-man references
that'll kind of clarify what's going on with
their spider-man easter eggs and we will get
a brand new spider-man 3 no way home trailer
sometime really soon too of course i'll do videos
for everything we also have the loki episodes that
are coming up that'll be the next big series that
i'll be doing videos for so make sure you have
alerts enabled so you don't miss any of those
episodes while you wait for everything click
here for my morbius trailer easter eggs and click
here for my brand new marvel what if trailer and
learn all about the multiverse avengers team
that they're putting together on that show
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!